I love building and operating data
centers I'm Joe cada vice president of
data centers at Google I'm responsible
for managing the teams globally that
design build and operate Google's data
centers we're also responsible for the
environmental health and safety
sustainability and carbon offsets for
our data centers this data center here
in South Carolina is one node in a
larger network of data centers all over
the world of all the employees at Google
a very very small percentage of those
employees are authorized to even enter a
data center campus
I think the Google Data Centers really
can offer a level of security that
almost no other company can match we
have a information security team that is
truly second to none you have the
expression they wrote the book on that
well there are many of our information
security team members that have really
written the books on best practices in
information security protecting the
security and the privacy of our users
information is our foremost design
criteria we use various layers of
higher-level security the closer in to
the center of the campus you get so just
to enter this campus my badge had to be
on a pre authorized access list then to
come into the building that was another
level of security to get into the secure
corridor which leads to the data center
that's a higher level of security and
the data center and the networking rooms
are the highest level of security all of
our racks don't really look like a
traditional server rack these are custom
designed and built for Google so that we
can optimize the servers for Hyper
efficiency and high performance
computing to me the thing that amazes me
about
the data centers is the pace of
innovation and always challenging the
way we're doing things so when people
say that innovation in a certain area is
done that we've kind of reached the
pinnacle of what can be achieved I just
laughed
you